okay so everybody my name is Peter so
the title of the talk is great and
boosted regression trees in scikit-learn
and its joint work with shield loop is
sitting in the first row
I already got mentioned in the keynote
today so the goal of the talk is twofold
first I'd like to introduce you to a
very versatile supervised machine
learning method gradient boosting and
then show you how you can use it in
practice using psychically or so I'm
just curious who of you has actually
heard about creating boosting for just
quick hands up okay just a bunch of
fools
so for those who haven't heard about it
yet I'm actually pretty sure that all of
us here have already used it today so
there's quite a lot of evidence that
whole major search engine companies like
Google Bing Yandex Oh Yahoo use it for
web page ranking but it's actually not
limited to this application domain so it
can be used for a variety of problems
and if you look at a winning solution to
prestigious data mining prices such as
the Netflix price or the General
Electric's flight quest or the heritage
half price you will notice the gradient
boosting was a key ingredients in all of
them and just a sort of a geeky side
note something very similar to the
technique that we'll discuss now is has
also been used in the Atlas experiment
at certain last year basically to detect
interesting collisions in a large
hydronic Collider so the outline of the
talk basically I will spend the next
five to ten minutes on some machine
learning basics and discuss decision
trees then I'll give you a quick
introduction to gradient boosting
focusing on intuition then I'll show you
how you can use it in practice using the
implementations I could learn I'll
conclude the talk with some a case study
on predicting color housing prices in
California so whoops quickly about us so
she'll he's a PhD student at the
University of liège in Belgium
focusing on machine learning in
particular tree ensembles and he's a
psyche loan developer since 2011 prime
offer and maintainer of decision tree
module and random forests and extra
trees and for my part I've been doing
Python and machine learning for about
six years now
the psychic learning developer since
2010 working on
to articulate descent and gradient
boosting mostly and I'm here with a
predictive briefly of analytic startup
called data robot so there are two of us
here so in case you're interested in
this topic please touch base ok basics
so just to get us all on the same page
totally where this talk is about
supervised machine learning and in
supervised machine learning as usually
we assume that our data comes in and a
set of examples basically pairs of x and
y where x are so-called feature vectors
which are basically Viktoria
descriptions of the objects for which
you want to generate predictions so in
case of web page ranking this could be
like one feature could be the number of
terms in the query or the number of
overlapping terms between the query and
the URL and the title type of the page
or like the page rank of the page and
the response on the other hand why this
could either be a real valued number in
which case you call it a regression
problem for example predicting the price
of a stock or it could be a mutually
exclusive class level in which case we
call it the Kecak classification problem
suggests like whether or not a web page
is relevant to a given query the goal in
supervised machine learning is basically
to find a function that basically maps
from X to Y and we want to find a
function which the Dro a new unseen data
is minimal and this is usually measured
by some kind of loss function which is
just a function of the ground truth and
our model predictions and so one common
approach to supervised machine learning
has been around for decades now are
decision trees and in particular cart so
classification and regression trees by
new Brian and colleagues and decision
tree is basically a binary tree so it
recursively partitions the input space
using this feature threshold function
you can see here so this like an example
from California housing data set so the
task here is to predict the median house
price of areas in California based on
features such as the median income in
this area or the average number of rooms
of houses in this area and you can see
basically these internal speed nodes
they gate examples through the tree
until they eventually end up in one of
those leaves and those leaves contain
constant prediction
so in a case of regression it's usually
all training the mean of all training
examples that ended up in a particular
leaf in case of classification that's
usually a class probability distribution
but basically everything that follows
from now I already talked about
regression trees and you can actually
use those in scikit-learn using
basically no tree marking decision tree
classifier and regressor so if you look
at what kind of functions can be
approximated by those regression trees
then I show you here just a quick toy
example so we have one feature X and the
response Y so it's a regression problem
the light blue curve shows you the
ground truth and what I did basically I
was just picked randomly 80 X values
evaluated the ground truth and then
added some random Gaussian noise
component on top of this and as I told
you before the leads in the decision
tree basically contain constant
predictions so the kind of functions
that we can model using regression trees
are these kind of piecewise constant
functions so the green line here shows
you a tree of depth one so it just has
one spoken all the Drude and two leaves
below that and you can see we have like
two constant segments and this one Bend
and the deeper we grow our trees the
more leaves we can accommodate which
means the more constant segments we have
to model the data and more variance we
can capture in the data and so system
trees are like one of the major
advantages that they are very
interpretable so you can simply plot
them look at them you can actually also
generate rule sets based on decision
trees but they have one big disadvantage
which is they have pretty poor
predictive performance so nowadays they
actually I hardly used alone but rather
in so-called 3d asam's and so tree
ensembles are just basically averaging
aggregating a large number of trees and
like those coming in free flavors like
random forests bagging or boosting and
random forests we heard about yesterday
but in Linda's talk buying is very
similar to two random forests and
boosting which is the subject of this
talk is actually quite different from
the other two and but we have
implementations of all them in
scikit-learn in the
samos package right so gradient boosting
so a great impulsive regression tree is
a basically very flexible nonparametric
method that you can use for both
classification and regression okay and
in this sense they are very similar to
nonlinear support vector machines or
random forests or even k nearest
neighbor but in our point of view they
have a number of strengths our
combination of strengths which make them
quite unique and for me is really sort
of the Swiss Army hammer of supervised
machine learning so they you can really
apply it to most problems I came across
so far so one of those advantages are
highlighted here so first they work
really well with heterogeneous data and
but a basically meet data were featured
on measured on different scales like in
this housing example we had the median
income is measured on a very different
scale as the average number of rooms for
example and this is in sharp contrast to
other machine learning problems such as
pretty thing whether an image contains a
face or not we're basically all your
features are very homogeneous like pixel
intensities or text classification
problems with all the features are
basically term frequencies then second
rating boosting supports different loss
functions okay so you can pick a loss
function that fits your problem at hand
and you don't have to resort to any kind
of proxy loss function and obtain my
spread rather so it can do things like
if you have lots of mislabeled examples
you can do things like robust loss
functions for regression for example but
you can do also custom loss functions
for ranking problems which is actually
quite useful and third they
automatically detect a nonlinear feature
interaction so you don't need to hard
code feature interactions and you also
don't need to incorporate like yeah some
kind of prior knowledge in form of a
kernel something like this and they
really give you a state of VR predictive
accuracy but it's still not a total
black box so you can still look into
them and see how predictions are derived
which is also quite different from for
example neural networks or again like
support vector machines but also again
we're a bunch of disadvantages one of
them would sit shares with quite a lot
of other machine learning methods use it
that it requires quite careful tuning
okay another one is that it's actually
quite slow to train but it's
really faster predict I think that's
what another reason why they also use it
for web page ranking and I mean the only
really limitation of the model is that
and that again is shared shares with
other tree based methods is that it
cannot be used to extrapolate so if your
problem requires extrapolation you
should rather deal with that outside of
great boosting okay so boosting as I
told you for boosting is an ensemble
technique and you can think of an
ensemble is basically a mixture of
experts okay and boosting differs quite
a lot from like random forests in a
sense and how it actually learns this on
song and it does it in a sequential
manner so basically each member of the
ensemble is an expert on the errors of
its predecessor and sort of one tardy
the first and the first practical
boosting algorithm was actually other
boost by your friend and rocks appearing
and way it works it's sort of
iteratively rewrites training examples
based on errors and I've sketched this
here so this is now a classification
problem task is to separate the records
from the from the glue dots and so we
start on with some you know initial
decision tree okay we make a bunch of
errors we now sort of up wide the errors
and down by the examples we got wrong
and then we fit the second tree on this
we righted data
this puts not more emphasis on the
examples on the upward at examples less
instances on the downloaded examples and
we continue doing that for hundreds or
even thousands of iterations and then
the final model is just the aggregation
of all those individual predictions and
again you can use a new scikit-learn
adaboost classifier or regressor now
this was a huge success practically
speaking I think one of the most seminal
studies that used a low boost was a face
detector by Paul viola and Mike Jones
for those of you who have had a machine
learning class probably know the picture
I think it's still one of the most
highly cited papers in Xin learning and
yeah
fronting Shapira also won the greater
prize for their work on boosting and
other boost in particular and so this
raised the attention of a statistics
community and they looked at boosting
from like in particular jerome friedman
he looked at boosting from this
statistical point of view and his major
contribution was basically to general
boosting to arbitrary loss functions and
that's how we came up with this gradient
boosting idea and I think the only
intuition that I would like to convey
here is that of residual fitting so now
this is again motivated in the context
of a regression problem so we have on
the Left start again from the left here
we have the ground truth
one feature X the response Y so you can
think of this as the box of this of your
favorite movie kind of and the way
cranium boosting works like the first
tree we fit on the original data ok but
and the second tree instead of fitting
in on a on a rewrite it version of the
original data we rather fit it to the
residuals of the first tree so consider
this one so the first tree fits the step
function to the original data okay and
you can see the first guy here was
spot-on so the residual is 0 in the
second tree the same as this guy here
which is going to 0 the other ones are
just relative because we have a constant
prediction here and we then fit the
second tree to the residuals and
continue doing that for hundreds of
thousands of iterations and the final
model is just the sum of all those
models and the way he motivated this was
in the context of gradient descent or
what he calls functional gradient
descent so if you consider the case of
least squares regression where a loss
function is basically just the squared
residual you can think of the residual
is something like the proportional to
the negative gradient of the loss
function with respect to your current
model output and now the idea is that
you do steepest descent on top of this
so each progression tree approximates
the negative gradient and successive
tree is just the successive successive
gradient steps so a final model is just
all gradient steps tracing back and now
the neat thing if this is that if you're
interested in not yeah in any kind of
differential loss function you can just
plug that in compute this negative
gradient then you get these two of the
residuals and it can fit a regression
tree on that and it's basically the
gradient boosting model so now we are
not only limited to things like square
error like the red curve here we can
rather use different loss functions such
as absolute error any kind of Hooper
rise version of this or we can also go
like here on the right hand side Locke
lost the green curve basically gives you
a logistic regression model but we can
also use like exponential loss the blue
curve there which actually recover that
we recover than the other boost
algorithm that we talked about before so
this is basically how gradient boosting
works actually fairly simple algorithm
you can even show it in pseudocode on
one slide and i've said a lot to do that
so right now let's see if how I can
actually use it in practice in in
scikit-learn and I so told you before
all of our ensemble estimators are
located in the SKA ensemble package so
you can just from SQL ensembl import
gradient boosting classifier in this
case I'll just make a classification
example then we have like we generate
some synthetic data using an example
that they also used in the elements of
statistical learning the book then you
can see here you basically instantiate
an estimator and pass it a number of
hyper parameters such as the number of
trees that you would like to fit and the
depth individual trees then you can
simply fit that to your training data so
the training data it's usually like a
two-dimensional umpire array encoding
your feature matrix and then the
corresponding response is why okay and
once the model is fit you can generate
predictions using our like predict
interface so in the case of a
classification if you do estimated or
predict you basically get class labels
back if you do estimated top underscore
F top pretty underscore probability you
get class probability estimates so the
implementation is mostly written in pure
Python and umpire so it's actually very
easy to extend so if you want to write
your own loss functions for example and
it turns out that the only critical
section in the code is actually learning
of those decision trees and here we
build on top of our decision tree
regressor implementation which is
written in seitan and one thing
interesting thing noting here is that
turns out it's quite so the kind of
trees that we build for random forests
actually quite different from the trees
that we build for boosting so in random
forests we usually grow very deep trees
lots of randomization
and in boosting we rather draw very
shallow trees and hardly any
randomization and this is quite a lot of
implications for for the tree growing
algorithm so what we do in scikit-learn
so fortunately is in one year ago
rewrote our decision tree implementation
so that you can actually use different
strategies to train your trees and we
use a custom strategy for gradient
boosting that basically does pre-sorting
of the data and unfortunately this
requires another memory copy so it's not
as memory as efficient as for nm forests
but it works quite better for for
shallow trees that we using in boosting
okay so if you look at the function
approximation capabilities of such a
creating boosting model so here again
that's the same data that we that we had
before in the decision tree case and the
solid red curve shows you basically the
approximation of the decision tree model
sorry gradient boosting model with 2000
decision trees all of depth one so you
can see we get a fairly good
approximation and the way I actually
plotted this was after each tenth tree I
added I plotted one line so this is
actually this shows you like 200 lines
actually and so the first line you can
barely see it here but it's like a very
constant model like like basically this
one here with the one band in here and
it's fairly poor approximation to the
data right so it hardly captures the
variance it only gets the guys here on
the left right but as we add more trees
so this actually like we would call this
a high bias low variance solution so it
hardly gets the variance of the data and
that's actually quite constrained in the
number of functionality model only very
constant functions but as we add more
trees you can see we can capture more
variance in the data and also the bias
goes down so now we have much less
constraints from the kind of function
suite then we can actually model and
it's usually machine learning this kind
of usually call this like the model
complexity okay so the more trees we
have the more complex the model gets the
more variance we can capture but this
model complexity usually comes at a
price so this basically just another
visual depiction of the data we saw
before but now in addition to those 80
training data points
so sampled 20 test data points that I
didn't use for model fitting and I
showing out two curves basically the
blue curve shows you the training error
is a function of the number of
estimators our proxy for model
complexity and the red curve shows you
the testing error again it's a function
of the number of estimators if you look
at the training error so if it starts
rapidly decreasing okay start slowing
down at about 100 trees but then it
still continues to decrease and at about
1000 trees we sort of reach nearly zero
now if you look at the testing around
the other hand it also starts rapidly
decreasing but slows down and then
actually it reaches its minimum failure
after about 120 trees and then it even
starts increasing again
okay so what's happening here so it
seems like that the model is so much
capacity already that it starts picking
up the idiosyncrasy of our training data
okay so it starts memorizing the
training data and in particular this I
talked about this Gaussian noise
component that I added to our training
data so any fitting this this random
noise so to speak doesn't help the model
to generalize better to make better
predictions right so this is what we
usually call the machine learning is
overfitting okay and you can see this
nicely by this large gap between the
training and test error okay and it's
the nemesis of everybody doing machine
learning and so one of the cool things
about gradient boosting is that it
actually provides you a number of knobs
that you can turn in order to control
this overfitting behavior so there are
basically three types of knobs that I
would just quickly go over which are
quite important to use it successful in
practice so one of them is the tree
structure the other one is the shrinkage
it's something called shrinkage and the
last one is called sohow's degrading
boosting those are usually summarized in
the term regularization okay so the
first three structure so yeah so the
depth of the individual trees as well as
the number of trees those are both
aspects of model complexity okay and
basically takeaway message here is the
maximum depth of the tree controls the
degree of feature interactions that a
model that you can actually model right
so if if you want to model that their
interactions between latitude and
longitude you need at least the tree of
that too in order to accommodate this it
need at least like one split note split
some latitude another one below the
speeds and longitude or vice versa and
now unfortunately you don't know this
advance in the in advance so but it
usually it's fine to assume that it's
the number of interactions is fairly low
so usually like frequent pauses maximum
depth of about four to five so I usually
use four to six but hardly tea put in
ten six and then there's another thing
that you can do it's called min samples
leave a parameter that you can assign to
the model that basically is a constraint
on the minimum number of samples that
end up in a leaf so this avoids like
creating a leaf for just like one
outlier or something like this so it
adds more bias again to the model makes
it more constraint so the second
regularization technique that's actually
quite important it's called shrinkage
and the idea here is basically that you
do slow learning by shrinking the tree
predictions by some small scalar which
we call the learning rate and the
analogy to this is basically a step size
in a gradient descent procedure so you
know just make smaller steps and the
model basically now has to sort of
reinforce concepts so quite a lot of
trees get actually quite redundant but
it works really well in practice so
unfortunately for if you lower the
learning rate it now requires a much
higher number of estimators okay so I've
sketched this here in the plop again the
the red and the blue curve show you the
reference curves that we had before and
I also train the gradient boosting model
with the learning rate of 0.1 and it's
the training error is shown in light
blue testing error is shown in orange so
you can now see that in order to get to
the same level of training error you
actually need a much larger number of
trees okay like in this case 200 more
trees but eventually you end up with a
lower testing error and much more
importantly it actually stays down there
for much longer and you can also see
that a difference the gap between the
training and testing error and all sort
of got much closer so now we sort of
effectively combat at this overfeeding
behavior and ended up with a much better
model actually so it's very important if
you use gradient boosting definitely
want to tune this parameter
so the last thing is called stochastic
gradient boosting it's very similar to
what we do in random forests so just the
randomization trick it comes in two
flavors one is to basically randomly
subsample the training data before you
grow each tree you can do that using the
sub sample argument and the other one is
to basically randomly sample them the
number the feature set before you create
a split node it's again like the same
thing that random forests does basically
and takeaway message here is that
actually both lead to improved accuracy
and also important reduced run time so
we also definitely want to do this and
based on my experience if you have a
sufficiently large number of features it
actually I would recommend using just
this approach max features usually works
much better okay so now introduced
already a number of sort of hyper
parameters and knobs that you need to
turn when you want to use this
successfully and it's usually machine
learning is kind of tedious to to set
those so I usually follow this recipe
here there's also like sort of best
practice but a number of people that use
gradient boosting and basically start
out with setting the number of trees
sort of as highest as computationally
possible like this depends again on your
data set and hardware you have available
but let's pick like 3,000 and then
basically you can tune the hyper from it
is using grid search and scikit-learn
you can do this quite conveniently so
you specify a parameter grid so in this
case I'll usually train these four high
parameters to learning rate the maximum
depth the minute samples leave and the
max features and then you instantiate an
estimate object here and then you pass
the estimator and the parameter grid
through this grid search TV object and
if you call fit with your training data
what it basically does it exhaustively
enumerate all possible hyper on with the
combinations and gives you back the best
setting and yeah you can also do that
using multi processing with chop lip
game shop today and if that doesn't work
it actually fairly easy also to hook
this up with ipython parallel
so it can run on the cluster okay and
finally I make an all-round tuning where
it's just said the Lambeth tree is even
higher and then just keep turning the
learning rate a bit more okay so that's
basically how you can so the basics of
how you use gradient boosting in in
practice successfully and now just
quickly go over a case study with some
real-world data so for this I I pick the
California housing data set which is I
think quite interesting for gradient
boosting a couple of reasons so the task
here is basically to predict the log
median house value for census groups in
in California so there are roughly
20,000 of those groups each of them has
eight features such as the median income
in a particular area the median house
age in this area the latitude and
longitude of the area and like the
number of occupancy I think per per
house the average number of our
commercial house and the metric we are
interested in this mean absolute error
on an 80/20 train test split in order to
stay consistent with other studies that
use the same data set so one on the one
hand we have heterogeneous features as I
said before like the the median income
is measured on a very different scale as
delet longitude for example and you can
also see that actually those features
are quite differently distributed so
median income is very left-field we have
this kind of bimodal distributions for
that if you're in longitude which also
has some implications for other machine
learning methods that we use on this
data set and the second challenge is
that we have quite a bit of nonlinear
future interactions so in particular
latitude longitude so spatial geospatial
data is quite important for this one so
here's a quick rundown on some of the
methods that I tried for this on this
all of them are available in
scikit-learn and so the takeaway message
here is that gradient boosting actually
does there's a decent shop here also
compared to random forests and like the
major reason for this really is the
training boosting was the only model
that could sort of optimize the target
metric mean absolute error directly so
all other methods actually had to use a
proxy like random forests optimizes
squares same as rich regression and
least-squares is actually not a good fit
for this data set so the the the
responses are actually they contain
quite some outliers and so these squares
put a lot of emphasis in getting those
outliers right and this actually it
doesn't help you learn in final
evaluation metrics so mean episode error
doesn't doesn't evaluate this actually
so this I think one of the reasons why
it actually works quite well on this
data set support vector machines on the
other hand they optimize something very
similar as mean absolute error but they
really work not very well with
heterogeneous data so you can see this
actually does quite worse than gradient
boosting so you would have to do much
more feature engineering and much more
feature transformations in order to get
to a similar level of performance and
for all these methods actually I use
squid Sergent and tuned all the high
parameters that are necessarily to get
actually decent performance here and you
look at the training time you will also
see that it's actually quite high for
grading boosting but if you look at
those training tests curves that we saw
before you also see that actually the
test error starts to converge quite
quickly so we would have probably ended
up with just half the number of trees
and get the same level of performance so
one of the neat things also creating
boosting is that it is not at all
blackbox okay so you can still look into
the model and see what's what's actually
going on and we saw this actually
yesterday also in the Linda's talk on
random forests that you can get this
variable importancy which tells you
roughly okay which are the relevant
features for this data set and you can
see here for example median income is by
far the the the most important one but
the other ones still very important and
but this test just wants one part of the
story okay
so it doesn't tell you anything about
how the features actually interact with
the response actually how they interact
with each other so one way you can do
here is to look into so called partial
dependency plots and it's also what we
provide in scikit-learn but which
currently unfortunately only works for
gradient boosting so it actually would
work for random forests as well
so this basically just goes some of them
show you the effect of a certain feature
on the response so here on the on the
upper upper row on the left hand side
you can see the interaction between the
median income and the response so as we
said median income is like the most
important variable for its data set and
you can see there's roughly a linear
relationship between the median income
and and the log-house value that we get
in the specific region
another thing that that's probably
interesting here house age doesn't seem
to have like a clear effect on the
response so you can say the house edge
on its own like has has any clear effect
but if you look at two-dimensional
two-way partially pendency plots so here
I show you the average occupancy on the
x-axis and average house edge on the
y-axis and basically the the part of the
response is just the contour here so you
can see something something very
interesting here so it seems like that
above an average occupancy of free house
age doesn't matter
doesn't affect the house price okay but
if you look at if the average occupancy
is about two okay so probably in in
financial or economic areas or in the
cities you can see that the house data
actually has quite a lot of effect on
the response so the older the house the
higher the price use okay so these kind
of things we can so that it's actually
pretty convenient and it's you could
actually in principle do the same thing
for other models as well but this
computational extremely expensive and
for three based efforts it actually
comes pretty cheaply and so one of the
problem or interesting things is when
you do the same thing for latitude and
longitude and here you can you can see
that all other things being equal the
house prices at the coaster more are
higher than in the interior okay so it's
something sensible and you can also like
zoom into one of those areas you can see
that the model give because it had
already has quite a lot of complexity it
also measures this on a very fine scale
actually so you can see here differences
in the Bay Area again like this averages
overall
other features so it just looks at
lecture knowledge good
so I'm actually much unlike like my time
says 31 minutes what you said 10 mins
yeah 40 okay but including question
answering okay perfect okay so I will
conclude here basically so yeah so I
presented to you gradient boosting as a
very flexible nonparametric technique
that you can use for classification and
regression problems and it's really
applicable to a variety of problems I
mean from web page ranking to
environmental niche modeling and we
already have a kind of solid and sort of
Pettibon implementation in scikit-learn
actually been used extensively in data
mining competitions okay so at least
like for those of them that I've
highlighted here the winning solution
used this implementation it's about
three years old now so like they're
really diverse like starting from sales
forecasting to a competition where Jill
and I were involved where basically the
task is to predict the presence of North
Atlantic right whales on underwater
microphone recordings based on just
spectral analysis this was a competition
by Emerson on information security this
one was another one where shield and I
were involved were basically the task
was to predict the output of a solar
farm based on a numerical weather
prediction model basically and the last
one where competition I think it was
something good chemistry but I don't
know for sure and actually already
company is also using this
implementation so I know at least like
two companies that actually use it in
production already and maybe actually
some of you have used it today
okay so that's the end of my talk I
would rather go forward with questions
yeah
how do we calculate across probability
in a decision trees in the decision
trees is it's basically just the number
here the frequency of classes and then
normalized by the number of samples that
ended up in a particular leaf okay
across no no sorry in gradient boosting
we don't use classification trees the
only rules use regression trees so there
it's basically you basically optimize
the log loss like in logistic regression
that's a good question that pops up on
the mailing list Carla actually it
doesn't work with sparse data our
current implementation so it doesn't
give you a yeah it would convert it to
dense data and and actually like I don't
really mix down the topic because like
this cannon tree based methods the way
they work is they recursively partition
the data okay and if a data is bars then
like if you if you partition on a sparse
feature the the partition that you get
below is very small and so you can't
grow a tree is very deep so for boosting
in actually would work a bit but for
random forests and so it actually I
don't think it's necessarily good idea
but I've heard that people are actually
working on it now so maybe it will end
up in the trunk pretty soon I don't know
yes I questions what do you have a like
a reference for your advice on the
tuning of the parameters like that yeah
yeah actually I've had yeah I strongly
increment you go just to to scikit-learn
website and there we have references for
gradient boosting and there is basically
there is an r package called GBM from
Greg Ridgeway and it's like the
reference implementation for gradient
boosting it's a really great package and
and he has extensive documentation on it
and everything that he says there
applies to to this implementation as
well and to be honest like I actually
added the
they're certainly like this recipe that
I gave you is more or less let the
saying that he also suggests this
exercise were like a scientific one so I
on that God he presented that was sort
of looking at a single point in time
like the 1990 census yeah like what
would be a more interesting question for
a lot of us would be trying to predict
the future house prices by starting to
make sure we have now yeah I guess I
before that during that is anybody
actual to that end with these sorts of
trays they like work well for that sort
of problem or you get into the
extrapolation sort of spice okay a good
question so the the first part of the
question was like why I picked this data
set and if would it work well so I just
pick the data set because I think it's
interesting for gradient boosting
because of the two challenges so I'm not
that much into the house price
prediction actually but the second part
is extrapolation yeah so that's a big
deal for for three based methods but it
usually the way you can actually handle
it is if you have if you have trend in
the data you can you can D Trent the
data first and then apply those methods
and to be honest like I've done machine
doing now for a bunch of years I haven't
came into so many problems that required
extrapolation on this scheme but maybe
I'm just not working yeah on these kind
of problems but definitely yeah and one
one way you could also do here is you
can also use those the gradient boosting
model to transform your data so you
basically then transform the data in
that your new feature space is just the
predictions of the individual trees okay
and you what you could do is run a look
one run a simple linear model on top of
this and this would would work in this
case nothing yeah so it would definitely
get then trained okay
anybody else good question
so you mean the the high parameters that
I get out with for example three
thousand trees and if I just pick 100
trees if they would still be the best
have run parameters so this is
definitely not true because the learning
rate is very sensitive on the on the
number of trees so we have quite a lot
of interactions between those type of
parameters but usually it's really the
more trees the better it's like in
random forests you actually don't need
to number of trees so much just do as
much as possible yeah Chile has probably
more on that okay first